by now we've all heard stories about
shop selling toilet paper for 10 bucks a
roller $70 bottles of hand sanitizer on
eBay and we just boil with outrage is
there anything lower than price gouging
during a crisis I mean what kind of a
monster sees people desperate and
fearful and thinks hey I can make a
killing off this but you might be
surprised to know that there is one
group of people who actually think it's
not such a bad thing no it's not the
gougers themselves it's Economist's in
2012 the IGM forum conducted a poll of
over 50 respected economic experts about
a proposed Connecticut law against price
gouging and found that only 7 percent
agreed with it which is surprising
considering that over two-thirds of
states have such laws on the books
the wording varies from state to state
but gouging is typically defined as
raising prices on essential goods during
a disaster or shortage to a level that's
unfair excessive or unreasonable you
might already see why people who deal
with numbers all day might have a
problem with this how do you quantify
unreasonable what amounts to unfair most
people would find a 200% increase
excessive but some states will punish
even a 10 to 20% hike state attorneys
general across the country are swamped
with complaints about kovat related
price gouging and in the last couple
weeks some charges are starting to be
filed by the end of March Amazon had
removed over half a million listings and
suspended almost 4,000 sellers for
violating their fair pricing policies
but many economists claim that this
reaction does more harm than good prices
they say are a way of allocating
resources to the places where they are
valued most and that becomes even more
important when resources are scarce like
during shortages natural disasters and
endemics imagine that you're out of
toilet paper so you put on your face
mask and rush down to your corner market
and find out that they still have a few
packs left but they've raised the price
from $2.99 to $6.99 even though that's
more than double what you're used to
paying you really need that TP so you
fork over the money and storm Holmes
certain that you got hosed speaking of
getting hosed if you had a bad day you
wouldn't be in this predicament but says
the economist well you didn't know was
that earlier today your neighbor Ted
visited the same store
Ted's a bit of a doomsday prepper and
when he heard that toilet paper was in
short supply he decided to stock up by
buying every roll the store had that is
until he heard how much it would cost
not wanting to blow a week's wages on TP
he didn't really need Ted ended up
leaving with only two packs so if it
weren't for that high price there
wouldn't have been any toilet paper left
for you you needed it more than Ted so
the pricing efficiently distributed it
to you instead of him though it may seem
unfair these economists argue that
pricing is a better system for
determining who gets what rather than
first come first serve or fisticuffs in
the parking lot in times of scarcity
high prices discourage hoarding and
encourage conservation at least in
theory in the real world we do see
examples of how gougers exacerbate
shortages like the guy in tennessee who
famously hoarded 17,000 bottles of hand
sanitizer to sell online he probably
wouldn't have gone from store to store
or buying every bubble he could find if
he knew he couldn't jack up the price
but economists will claim that even
so-called entrepreneurs like him serve a
function in times of crisis by
efficiently moving goods from places
where they have them to places where
they need them for instance if a
hurricane disrupts a town's water supply
people from other counties will happily
Drive truckloads of water to the
stricken area if they're allowed to
charge prices high enough to make it
worth their while eventually the
enticement of big profits will attract
so much water that the shortage will end
and prices will normalize again in
theory economists tend to look at big
pick
some long time frames it's a lot harder
for governor in the middle of a disaster
to tell citizens I know you can't afford
to feed your family now but don't you
see at some point down the road the
market will stabilize that wouldn't go
over well
just because someone can't afford an
inflated price doesn't necessarily mean
they need the resource less than someone
who can yet such people seem to get left
out of these equations as economist
Angus Deaton said in his response to the
IGM forum poll efficiency is less
important than distribution under such
conditions whether it's morality or
biology humans seem to have an almost
universal conviction that in times of
crisis everyone should be pulling
together to help each other not looking
for ways to make a buck and people who
break that code are severely condemned
just ask our buddy in Tennessee who
received a ton of hate mail and death
threats from his unwanted infamy and
eventually agreed to donate his
stockpile to avoid prosecution
interestingly this societal judgment is
one of the reasons that economists tend
to find laws against price gouging
unnecessary in a classic example if a
local hardware store jacks up the price
of snow shovels the day after a blizzard
townspeople might get angry and punish
the storm owner by taking their business
elsewhere in the future so sellers who
care about their reputations already
have a powerful motivation not seem
exploitative or greed while this
motivation may not apply to an out of
state entrepreneur hoping to make a
one-time profit by selling overpriced
water it applies very much to large
corporations who carefully manage their
brands after being called out for
allowing third parties to price gouge on
their platforms mega retailers like
Amazon and Walmart are now bending over
backwards to assure their customers that
they don't cotton to no dirty rotten
price Gaucher's and major grocery store
chains go to great lengths to keep their
supply chains operating during crises so
as not to be painted with the dreaded
scarlet G as long as big firms keep
prices relatively stable say economists
individual entrepreneurs should be
allowed to fill in the gaps by charging
whatever people are willing to pay as
heartless as economics can sometimes be
I have to admit it's kind of comforting
that our beliefs about right and wrong
or at least a part of the equation right
so according to economists price gouging
maybe serve some necessary function but
the price gougers should still be
treated like greedy jerks seems like a
paradox but I guess that's economics
we're cold numbers meat warm hearts and
that's our two cents
why don't know why fish don't freeze in
Antarctica or why this glacier looks
like it's bleeding
check out Antarctic extremes a new
series from Nova and PBS Digital Studios
join Kaitlyn Sachs and Arlo Perez as
they experience a world that is
sometimes harsh sometimes hilarious
sometimes gross but always thrilling
find Antarctic extremes on Terra PBS
Digital Studios new science channel
check out the episode in the description
below and tell them two cents sent you
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]
you